[Musica]
quanto sono davvero liberi i nostri
desideri
vorrei ragionare con voi su questo e per
farlo prendo in prestito un ricordo
lontanissimo che credo che la maggior
parte di noi abbia in comune è un film
che abbiamo visto quando eravamo bambine
e bambini
la storia infinita
la trama ve la ricorderete bastian è un
ragazzino costretto a vivere una realtà
che gli dà grande sofferenza e per
sfuggire a questa realtà si rifugia nei
libri cioè nel mondo dell'immaginazione
e della fantasia un giorno così facendo
si imbatte in un libro molto speciale la
storia infinita appunto che narra
dell'avanzata del nulla una forza
misteriosa e distruttrice in grado di
far scomparire il vasto impero di
fantasia
bastian leggendo segue per pagine e
pagine le avventure del giovane
guerriero atreju attraverso tutta una
serie di prove e pericoli per cercare di
fermare questo nulla ma non ci riesce
niente nessuno sembra in grado di
riuscirci fino a quando
bastian non si accorge di una cosa si
accorge che il vero protagonista della
storia che lui sta leggendo e lui stesso
è lui l'unico in grado di poter salvare
fantasia lo sconfinato impero
dell'infanta imperatrice che nel libro
dal quale il film è tratto viene anche
chiamata la
sovrana dei desideri
e non è finita qui
non solo quello che fa bastian nella
realtà è in grado di cambiare la trama
del libro che sta leggendo ma anche
quella storia è in grado di trasformare
la realtà in cui vive pasti
l'autore ci sta quindi dicendo che il
mondo dell'immaginazione e quello della
realtà sono connessi c'è un continuo
sconfinamento di uno nell'altro
ne deriverebbe che la nostra capacità di
nutrire uno dei due mondi influenza
l'altro la nostra capacità di immaginare
è in grado di influenzare la nostra
realtà è a sua volta quello che viviamo
e vediamo è in grado di influenzare la
nostra capacità di immaginare e così via
secondo l'autore poi c'è un ingranaggio
preciso che mette in moto questo
meccanismo non scopriamo alla fine del
film quando fantasia e ormai distrutta e
non rimane nulla se non un piccolo
granello di luce nella scena è tutto
buio e immersi in quel buio i due mondi
quello dell'immaginazione e quello della
realtà finalmente si toccano
perché è così buio domanda bastian e
dell infante imperatrice la sovrana dei
desideri a rispondergli
all'inizio è sempre buio ma aggiunge
fantasia può ancora risorgere dai tuoi
sogni dai tuoi desideri
c'è qualcosa che tu desideri
mi è sempre piaciuta questa idea del
desiderio come antidoto al nulla alle
forze negative distruttrici che noi
incontriamo nel mondo che abitiamo e
anche in quello che ci abita
questa suggestione io me la sono portata
dietro per tutto questo tempo
ancora oggi quando io sono disorientata
svuotata depressa quando è tutto buio
insomma io riparto da quella domanda
c'è qualcosa che tu desideri
il desiderio
spinge in avanti la vita
desiderare ci sembra la cosa più
naturale del mondo ci sembra un processo
spontaneo libero fisiologico che non ha
bisogno di nient'altro al di fuori che
di se stesso ma non è così perché gli
esseri umani
non possono desiderare quello che non
riescono a immaginare e possono
immaginare soltanto quello che hanno
visto vissuto o di cui in qualche modo
hanno fatto esperienza per esempio
attraverso le storie
la letteratura il cinema il teatro
l'arte in generale accendono
nostra immaginazione e come se ci
mettessero di fronte a un enorme
specchio in cui noi possiamo vedere chi
siamo e anche chi potremmo essere questo
specchio ci rivela a noi stessi e nel
contempo ci aiuta a comprendere gli
altri a capire il mondo la vita e a
immaginarla diversa da come noi la
conosciamo e fa tutto questo non
soltanto passando attraverso la nostra
parte razionale ma soprattutto
attraverso
l'emozione che uno dei canali più alti e
potenti di conoscenza e trasformazione
allora lasciate che io vi parli del mio
mondo che è il teatro in cui questo
questo momento di rivelazione è
particolarmente evidente perché lo
spettacolo teatro lo sapete si fa nuovo
ogni sera e attori e attrici e
spettatori e spettatrici fanno lo
spettacolo assieme affacciati su quello
che luigi uve definiva un cratere che
fiammeggia in silenzio intenti a fare
qualche cosa che non va soltanto in
profondità ma soprattutto in altezza
proiettato cioè nella verticale
dell'infinito
se questo scambio funziona il vero
spettacolo non avverrà sul palcoscenico
ma nella mente di chi sta guardando e
osservando e continuerà anche molto dopo
la chiusura del sipario riverberando per
molto tempo nella memoria di chi vi ha
assistito durante questa esperienza
quello che vediamo è capace di cambiarci
e di rinnovarci e lo facciamo insieme
come noi qui stasera
contribuendo a definirci come gruppo ea
costituire quello che young a chiamava
l'inconscio collettivo
quello che vediamo ci ispira ci orienta
ci guida ed è capace di generare
desiderio capace a sua volta come
abbiamo visto di trasformare la realtà
tutto questo è potente e come ogni
potere si porta dietro una grande
responsabilità
sono un'attrice è solo un attivista sono
una delle 28 attrici che ha fondato
l'associazione amleto nata nel 2020 con
lo scopo di contrastare le disparità e
le discriminazioni di genere e la
violenza nel mondo dello spettacolo per
anni noi attrice abbiamo contribuito a
creare quello specchio di cui parlavamo
prima per anni abbiamo interpretato
storie recitato in spettacoli dato voce
a centinaia centinaia di donne siamo
state serve e regine bisbetiche e
allegre comari
siamo state giulietta e cassandra nora e
medea la signorina julie e alcesti siamo
state un'infinità di madri di mogli di
figlie di sorelle abbiamo cioè ha avuto
l'onore ma anche la responsabilità di
rappresentare le donne sul palcoscenico
è capitato un certo punto che qualcuna
di noi vivesse un certo disagio un
l'essere al quale non riusciva a dare un
nome e di accorgersi di non essere la
sola a provarlo
allora abbiamo fatto una cosa ci siamo
messe assieme
e abbiamo deciso di cominciare a
osservare quello specchio con cui noi
ogni sera nutriamo l'immaginario di
spettatrici e di spettatori per prima
cosa abbiamo sostituito le sensazioni
con i numeri con le cifre con le
percentuali cioè con dei dati precisi
inconfutabili e incontrovertibili
abbiamo cominciato a contare le presenze
femminili sui palcoscenici più grandi e
importanti d'italia quelli dei teatri
che prendono maggiori finanziamenti che
raccolgono più pubblico che hanno
maggiore visibilità e ci siamo da subito
accorti di una cosa piuttosto curiosa
che più i palcoscenici diventano grandi
e importanti
più le donne su questi palcoscenici
diminuiscono fino ad arrivare a queste
percentuali
sui palcoscenici più grandi e importanti
d'italia
le attrici sono il 36 per cento
36 ma se le attrici sono il 36 per cento
indicativamente i personaggi femminili
sono il 36 per cento cioè le donne
rappresentate su quei palcoscenici sono
il 36 per cento
questi sono i numeri di una minoranza ma
noi donne non siamo una minoranza
noi siamo la metà del mondo e questi
numeri non ci rappresentano e non solo
le atre le registe su questi
palcoscenici solo il 17 per cento circa
le drammaturghe il 15 per cento questo
significa che la 80 85 per cento delle
storie che passa su questi palcoscenici
è fatta da un uomo lo sappiamo
le donne per secoli non hanno potuto
studiare non hanno potuto scrivere in
alcune epoca non hanno neanche potuto
recitare questi numeri raccontano la
nostra storia
questi i numeri
raccontano la nostra oppressione
in platea poi c'è una situazione
ribaltata cioè la maggior parte del
pubblico è formato da donne che quindi
pagano dei biglietti pagano degli
abbonamenti per sentirsi raccontare
delle storie scritte da uomini
il punto di vista con cui si osserva al
mondo è uno solo la voce con cui lo si
racconta è una sola tutto questo non è
privo di conseguenze
come ha osservato cima manda gozzi adc
raccontare un unica storia è pericoloso
perché crea stereotipi gli stereotipi
sono narrazioni fallaci e incomplete che
ci allontanano dalla vera conoscenza e
soprattutto possono trasformarsi in
gabbie in queste gambe
noi attrici veniamo messe molto presto
impariamo molto presto quindi quali sono
gli stereotipi che pesano sulle donne
sono stereotipi sul nostro corpo sulla
nostra età
stereotipi sulle nostre capacità sulla
nostra emotività
stereotipi su quelli che sono i nostri
desideri
questi stereotipi ching abbiano in
un'idea di femminilità che non ci
appartiene che non è reale come disse
carla lonzi
l'immagine femminile con cui l'uomo ha
interpretato la donna è stata una sua
invenzione
se sei un'attrice per fare la
protagonista dovrei essere fatta in un
certo modo se hai una fisicità che esce
fuori dai canoni lavorerà in meno ti
faranno fare sempre la stessa parte
dopo i 35 40 anni tenderei a scomparire
oppure a finire ai margini della
narrazione
secondo uno schema che si ripete da
decenni e che riguarda decisamente molto
meno gli uomini
quante volte abbiamo visto il giovane
principe amleto interpretato da attori
non più giovanissimi
quante volte abbiamo visto ai tanti
guerrieri interpretati da attori
decisamente fuori forma molto più raro
vedere una desdemona o una giulietta
interpretati da un'attrice che non sia
giovane e carina dopo i 50 anni sono
pochissime le protagoniste femminili
mentre tantissimi sono i ruoli di grandi
e autorevoli vecchi come nella vita non
si capisce come mai gli uomini
invecchiano e diventano autorevoli e le
donne invecchiano e scompaiono
sugli stereotipi
riguardanti le nostre capacità o meglio
sarebbe dire
incapacità che film spettacoli persino
cartoni animati hanno contribuito a
rafforzare noi potremmo stare qui per
giorni le donne sono troppo emotive le
donne sono dedite alla cura le donne non
sono portate per la matematica per il
comando le donne non sanno far ridere
per le donne la cosa più importante
rimane sempre l'amore l'uomo è il
creatore e la donna e la sua musa e poi
insomma se noi non abbiamo avuto grandi
artiste grandi scrittrici grandi poeti
grandi grandi pittrici ci sarà una
ragione no
certo che c'è una ragione ma non
riguarda le capacità delle donne
riguarda la dimensione politica e
storica che ha plasmato il mondo è che è
legata alla diversa distribuzione del
potere tra i generi le architetture
patriarcali si sono fondate su suo
pressioni e condizionamenti più o meno
visibili e hanno disegnato il mondo come
noi lo conosciamo
le rappresentazioni
molto spesso hanno contribuito a
rafforzare quegli schemi invece di
svelarne la mistificazione
ma se le donne
le ragazze le bambine non si vedono
rappresentate o non si vedono
rappresentate se non in funzione gli
uomini se non vedono rappresentata la
loro complessità ma si vedono appiattite
su ruoli e interpretazioni
bidimensionali allora in troiette ranno
l'idea di non essere interessanti di non
essere centrali nella costruzione della
trama del mondo o di esserlo solo a
patto di avere quelle caratteristiche
che il desiderio e lo sguardo maschile
proietta su di loro
quindi la rappresentazione non sta
nutrendo la loro capacità di immaginare
e allora è proprio il meccanismo del
desiderio che si inceppa andando a
compromettere la loro capacità di
generare realtà
voglio fare soltanto un esempio che
riguarda uno stereotipo
piuttosto
affermato secondo la quale le donne non
sarebbero portate per la scienza
allora nella scienza come molti altri
campi l'assenza di donne ha delle
ragioni storiche le donne non hanno
potuto studiare laurearsi lavorare in
quelle discipline e anche quando sono
riusciti a farlo hanno visto le loro
scoperte prese e attribuite a degli
uomini e guardate che questo fenomeno è
stato così diffuso da meritarsi un nome
tutto suo effetto giuditta quindi le
scienziate sono state cancellate
prima dalla realtà e poi dalle
rappresentazioni che di quella realtà
sono state fatte ecco noi non abbiamo
dati che possono indicarci quale impatto
negativo abbia avuto questa mancanza
nelle rappresentazioni sulla realtà però
abbiamo dei dati che possono aiutarci a
fare dei ragionamenti
per esempio nel 1993 la serie expense
fece impennare le iscrizioni di ragazze
a materie scientifiche e secondo una
ricerca riportata dal geena davis
institute il 63 per cento delle donne
che lavora in materie stem ha affermato
che il personaggio di dana scully
interpretato dall'attrice gillian
persone è servita loro da role model e
ispirazione questo viene chiamato the
scully effect così come il personaggio
della scienziata forense catherine
guillaud interpretato dall'attrice
margaret è il game berger in csi ha
contribuito a far aumentare in maniera
esponenziale le iscrizioni di ragazze in
quella materia scientifica viene
chiamato di csi
il test
e a proposito di scienza
la scoperta dei neuroni specchio
e il loro ruolo nell'acquisizione delle
informazioni
meccanismi neurali che stanno alla base
dell'interpretazione e dell'elaborazione
di noi di ciò che noi vediamo la
riorganizzazione dei comportamenti e
delle proiezioni
secondo delle proprietà predittive del
cervello
la scienza in pratica ha confermato
piano piano il rapporto tra
rappresentazione immaginazione realtà e
desiderio che una trama di fantasia come
quella della storia infinita aveva
semplicemente
ipotizzato e cioè
se io vedo
posso immaginare se io immagino posso
desiderare
se io desidero ho il potere di cambiare
la mia realtà e se io cambio la mia
realtà a poco a poco trasformo il mondo
vedere è potere
oggi noi abbiamo parlato di donne ma
soltanto per svelare il meccanismo ma
intere categorie di persone ancora oggi
in italia sono completamente escluse
dalle nostre rappresentazioni
dove sono le persone nere le persone
trans le persone con disabilità le
persone appartenenti a categorie
marginalizzate tutte quelle persone che
fanno parte della nostra vita insomma
dove sono sul piano simbolico si gioca
una partita molto importante
non si tratta soltanto di
intrattenimento quindi da questa sera
domandatevi cosa vi stanno facendo
vedere
domandatevi soprattutto cosa e chi non
vi stanno facendo vedere
pretendete altro
scegliete meglio desiderate meglio
cambiate il mondo
cazzi
[Applauso]
[Musica]